anti-racist groups depend for funding on
the being a problem so it doesn't serve
the interests if the problem goes away
or the problem is not what they say it
is so partly money to that I added the
fact that of course there are plenty of
people who have built their careers
their political careers on anti-racism
and they've made all sorts of friends
and allies on that basis and it would be
quite costly in terms of career for them
to start backtracking and you've also
got a very burgeoning diversity industry
these days going into major corporations
to train people on their unconscious
bias of course yes you're quite right so
there's that too so as as where the
business has expanded and and to to to
to start saying things are more
complicated means uh it's a threat to
business so ironically I I mean people
on the right can behave this way too uh
let's be clear about that but ironically
for the left uh there may be an element
of of commercial interest here that is
at stake